capturing sound what are you using it at
some point are you loud miking people I
said you know but like how does this
working my tools are like hammers and
nails okay I use I have a broad palette
of things and I I make selections that
have to do with the tonality of the
actor where are we in context with the
character how we experiencing this
character is it more of an internal
thing what you know where are we and the
characters are in the story so I use all
the traditional tools I'll use Japanese
might call the sank and for boom work
frequently and Shep's instance and
Newman's and I use a Danish lavalier a
lot made by DPA and also Japanese thang
and lavaliers and other tools many
different mics that that doesn't cover
it but it's it's not about technique
it's about context so I try I do and I
teach on this I you need to know all of
those pieces and how to apply them but
you need to not lose sight of that the
real key tool is the filmmaker the sound
man has to be a filmmaker
just like the cameraman has to be a
filmmaker has to understand the
directors intent and the context of the
particular situation and if you think in
those terms
it creates flow on a set you're you're
responding intuitively or premeditated
either way
based on what's what are we doing what's
the shot what's the scene where does the
scene fit in against the other scenes
you know how is the whole piece of cloth
going to be affected by the choices I
make in this particular moment and they
all have to have a an integration you
know I try not to come with an ideology
because the day I come and think I know
the whole thing is the day I should quit
because I stop learning and I'm not open
to what we're what we're really trying
to get to happen here so I don't know if
that answers your question but it's it's
it's an it's a really important piece to
me that that I don't come with a preset
notion of a book so all of those things
are true but it all goes towards the
idea of constructing a sound a mix in
the moment that's a lot like playing an
instrument a musical instrument that
keeps us inside that character that's my
threshold when we watch it as an
audience are you believe
that this is this character and they're
in this environment having this journey
everything that we do supports that so
if there's a noise that happens that's
unexpected my threshold is did it take
us out of the scene did it take us away
from the character if the answer's no
I'm not as emotionally disturbed by that
moment because I know that the core
thing is being protected if it does then
we're in a conversation Quentin or
whoever the director is hears it hears
an exposure here's a vulnerability it's
it's sometimes it's just a look you know
and it's not a big conversation let's go
again you know cuz he does not walk away
without having that in the can period he
just doesn't
he's absolutely failure cannot cope with
persistence and he is the most
persistent person I've ever seen in a
director's seat and I love that because
that's how I feel
you